who's that the girl in my class zero  friends super weird I thought we were  friends  why did you cut my friendship  Oh a fellow student marina Mills  committed suicide it was a video  uploaded origin ought to watch it I saw  the medical report it is insane this  whole corn umit's what's in this video  just magically appeared on your tablet  I'm not posting this did you try  changing your password yes yes I tried  everything she's been back in my friends  list you have no idea how crazy that is  to you  that is what code normally looks like  not this this isn't code  it's her it's possessing and haunting  them we've all been done  don't change your channel